think is where we got up to okay let's
just get our brains back into gear we've
got a point and it's equidistant from
this in the last scenario we did down
outside yeah good point I'm gonna whine
equidistant because you've got a line in
there that's why we threw in the
perpendicular distance for me off on
which admittedly is a bit tricky to
remember but if it encourages you
because the point the point
perpendicular distance formula right has
a point a line that you feed into it
right the lines here got in general for
the point at least when we're dealing
with locus right he's always gonna look
like this X Y alright so once you put
this into that form that's an X and
that's your wife
and then you just put it there okay so
even though perpendicular distance is a
bit hard to remember at least it's not
like she actually they do which is new
so if you haven't already
you
okay I'm gonna have to Kyle at ten
minutes that's fine
all right everybody done mmm how many
answers are there good question
oh yeah right lots of lots of questions
all right what are all these questions
coming from there coming from the fact
that we've got distance distance and
they're just positive right but actually
um you're sort of can have negative
distances right because that's why we've
got this whole part of the axis which is
negative right so you go in a negative
direction so that's why if the next tip
I'm gonna do is I'm going to square
everything and that's gonna one solve
the square root science and it's also
gonna get rid of this pesky absolute
value thing because if you square it
it'll you'll come out in the wash okay
so let's give this a go when I Square
this it'll be just without the spirit
side okay this will also be it's just um
that's just one all right so that's
perfect one then this thing here zero on
2xy minus one
that's all square you're happy that I'll
just square everything do you be careful
you're squaring by the way later on when
you're safe for instance so cuz I didn't
say that equidistant so because I said
the distance from the line is always
twice as much I put the number there
like to want to square everything it's
looking a span soon right but people
often forget to square it and it becomes
a tricky I should really be a four three
no let's keep going okay now I can
actually expand down there's no other
options I can have to try and simplify
this
however you should be able to sort
anticipate see how I've got Y minus
something squared and another Y minus
something squared there's gonna be a y
squared here and a Y squared here that
will cancel okay so this is gonna need
enough but we need to expand everything
first let's go
so there are my terms that cancel I was
up all the time to cancel to actually
just kind of so I'm going to lose all
the footage they can go into vanish what
am I left with
let's see yes I'm gonna move that minus
six so I'm gonna add it to both sides so
plus 6y back is before one over here and
I'm just going to divide through by four
okay so what does it mean I haven't
bothered to actually do any further work
or look at the discriminant of this if
you remember that from last year however
let's actually start to draw this up and
see what's going on
so when you create a set of axes there
the first thing you do is you put on the
important geometric features that were
described in the question right so I
have my y y equals 1 sorry yeah good
question so if you had this line versus
this line how would you describe the
difference it's it's uh well this one is
more is flatter or more shallow than
this one
okay in the same way if I took a
parabola it's just gonna be flatter and
if you're good if you went back to say
tree right the difference between this
and this is what we call the amplitude
right so it's the same thing just squash
down instead of going from 1 to negative
1 fish from the corner today that's it
ok good question now there's my line L
right where's my point why are you
coming three so one three
okay now just picture do you remember um
where we were standing
relation to the wall right without
knowing anything about you know what its
intercepts are what would you expect
this to look like well you can although
mr. lazy spot to stand right exactly
halfway between the point and the line
the wall and we do this the spots so
important we give it a special name it's
the vertex and then the rest of you sort
of moved off so it looks something like
this okay and you know there's a there's
Jesse because he was he was off on the
side right and everyone's going back and
forth so happy oh look at this this is
me just interpreting it geometrically
without looking at my equation okay but
now you could go and you could conclude
for instance that if you better did the
discriminant for this what kind of value
would you expect they're just going to
have the discreet and tells you about
roots right whether you've got them how
many you've got I have no real roots
here right so that would imply the
description is negative okay something
like that and it'll save you from
wasting your time trying to find roots
because they weren't exist
well they might be real anyway so you
don't graph and what's this pointy
bugger juice can you see it can you can
you read it off it's just nine on four
right because when you put x equals zero
these guys just vanish and you're left
with the constant tada
now on the sheet I'd like you to have a
go at these again be careful when you
read this you want to start by
identifying the key information you can
either circle it on the sheet or I like
to write it down because it helps get
into my head and then the first thing
you should always write ask that key
information is the equation that defines
it so far we've just been saying this
week was that okay but it might be
this is double that or this is this plus
one or something else read it carefully
the question we tell you okay and then
you can watch it too all right that's a
point-to-point so that's point one
that's point to a wide so using that
formula OK and that will tweet you go